last week I showed you how to make a
slideshow using an online web
application called Web 2.0 called photo
show look at last week's video for that
but if you're using Picassa you can do a
similar thing although not quite as
elegant and you can do it by doing the
following here I'm in Picassa I'm going
to click and select a few photos then
I'm going to go up to
create and click
movie when I click create movie I get a
chance of what size of movie do I want
I'm just going to do a small for this
particular demonstration with two
seconds between each photo and click
okay then we'll click okay again
depending on how many pictures you have
and how large the pictures are the movie
can take a little while to render once
the movie is finished Picassa opens up
the folder where the movie was placed
usually in the same folder wherever you
had the pictures so I'm going to double
click on the movie and play it for you
it uses the title of the folder that you
just had as well as the date when you
created the movie there's no music but
it does have some panning and zooming on
the transitions you can pull the movie
into Windows Movie Maker or any other
movie editor and add your own music and
even some more captions and other things
but at least it's uh something to get
you started and yet another hidden
feature in Picassa